vient de regrouper je laisse le bateau
au groupé et hop je viens juste basculer
sur le clan wade board ou en ski
nautique l'été est une période propice
aux initiations pour le club tourangeau
mais outre le loisir touraine ski
nautique qui compte désormais plus de
120 licenciés est aussi labellisé pour
la compétition et l'organisation de ces
championnats de france interligues est
une véritable reconnaissance du travail
accompli sur le lac des peupleraies on
est parti de zéro il y avait absolument
rien c'était la mare aux canards un
petit peu au départ donc on a dû
concevoir tous les aménagements mettre
toutes les installations aux normes aux
normes
nationale et internationale et puis
petit à petit on a organisé des
compétitions avec un niveau de plus en
plus important pour finalement cette
année à réussir à accueillir une
compétition nationale à savoir les
championnats de france interligues
dominé des championnats où vont
s'affronter toutes les ligues régionales
qui présenteront chacune une équipe
près de 100 compétiteurs devrait ainsi
s'affronter sur le lac des pas pleurer
en ce dernier week end de septembre
de gros investissements ont été
nécessaires pour pouvoir accueillir une
telle compétition
c'est un peu une épreuve test pour notre
club et puis pour les installations tout
simplement
donc voilà cette année on a fait de gros
efforts puisqu'on a fait amène enfin on
a aménagé un nouvel espace d'accueil de
60 un peu plus de 70 m² en partie pour
recevoir et accueillir ce championnat de
france on a investi dans un bateau tout
neuf de toute dernière génération
ce bateau là que vous voyez et c'était
le bateau qui avait servi pour les
championnats du monde l'année dernière
bien évidemment la ligue du centre val
de loire présenterait une équipe pour
ces championnats est là aussi
l'enjeu est important car il s'agit de
prouver que le ski nautique reste un
sport pratiqué à haut niveau dans les
différents clubs régionaux